welcome back to the iced coffee hour
this is tech lead and the iced coffee
hour has made
some pitiful amount like two bucks five
bucks whatever it is i probably lost
more than this in the crypto markets but
welcome yeah to this it's probably it's
nothing to you as a millionaire but to
us it is 191
9113 dollars in one penny is that
supposed to be a lot well it's like
nothing you guys
it's nothing it's a pitiful amount yeah
as you said it's supposed to be
something
but anyway we we're almost at two years
now yeah so it's almost two years with
adventures yeah again this is something
i just make or lose in a day every day
based on the crypto markets and
fluctuations
how much did you make or lose today in
crypto your entire portfolio millions
multiples of millions multiples of
millions
[Music]
it's just whatever ether scan tells me
it's just paper gains paper losses what
i do is i mint a coin for
and i sell it for like a dollar but if
i'm in 10 million coins i have a net
worth of 10 million you see that's
genius actually yeah well we got a lot
to cover today so first of all as a
background
i watched your channel
uh when you were at
x google x facebook so i i've seen
your progression
on youtube and like through your careers
working in in tech as a tech lead yeah
um
and then google x x meta ex-husband
ex-convict ex-sociopathic psychopath
technique
so it's hard to keep track of them
well but
just shows how far ahead i am with you
yeah
most people
but you know what i've uh almost got my
license now in nevada so i've taken all
the classes online i just got to stay
take the state exam and then i will be
licensed again in nevada so i will no
longer be an ex
leader i'll use you
yeah no but i've been i've been managing
my own property success maybe coming up
jeff bezos bill gates elon musk sure
myself
oh gosh anyway so i had you back on the
channel on the gram stefan show this
this would have been three years ago
had you on and then brought you back
very shortly after
when you made a video about your ex-wife
leaving you and she took your your kid
to another country yeah and this was
just a crazy story and i remember you
making these these videos just
discussing the subject
and these videos were just
not only very heartfelt but like were
gained like garnering millions of views
on on some of these topics uh and then
was it around that time that you were
like a tell a bit of your story here
because i think it's a very
tumultuous
uh probably in high school
i was already a straight a student
valedictorian right like very
traditional upbringing you could say
pave the road into becoming essentially
a software engineer i'd always been
interested in programming i got into
uc berkeley you know top three college
in the country maybe for a computer
science electrical engineering computer
science during that time i did spend a
year studying abroad in japan right and
that was probably one of the best years
of my life so you know travel and
minimalism are some things that
have really been instilled in me after
that came back i spent some time working
at sun microsystems for internship i did
an internship at microsoft a software
engineer i worked i went to uc san diego
for grad school for about a year went to
sony pictures worked there for a year
75k income at the time it was really
good and that was for old reason i was
hot stuff i was like 23
24 something like that
during my time there
i built my first app i taught myself uh
php web development full stack the
facebook apps were happening so
uh i launched that app and it took off
right so i made probably a million
dollars right there uh by the time i was
25 and
this is something i recommend to
everybody is you don't need to take like
i'm against taking risk
um
like i don't believe in taking risk your
life is far too valuable to to risk it
on anything like so i would do
both at the same time i did my side
hustle in the evenings and weekends
did my full-time job in the daytime
after that i went off and traveled
actually
doing the digital nomad thing
been to a bunch of different countries
worked from like
london the uk worked from hawaii for a
while worked from japan went to new york
for a while here and there and i kind of
went back and forth and alternated with
some
full-time jobs actually here and there
right so like i would go back to silicon
valley work in some app companies
one tony k income over at play them this
is an app company
worked at a groupon worked out some
startups
worked at some of my own ventures again
right making more apps and projects some
of those also blew up
so this is the time i made like 50 apps
or so you know like more than that a
bunch of different websites ideas that
failed some of them succeeded and made
maybe another
maybe another million dollars or so
right um
and then
probably at around that time i did go to
japan i met my wife over there i was
doing my own independent side hustles
during that time
and you know you can fill up these gaps
in your resume by saying like yeah i was
working on this venture this project
right that's how you can fill this up
came back
landed the job at google
and that set me on several years working
there as a tech lead
went to
uh transferred over to facebook after
that right voluntarily so that that was
a clean transfer
um and then during that time at facebook
i had also my youtube channel that i was
starting to do
so i went to microsoft too a lot of
people don't know that
but i did get married i had the kid my
wife from japan
so i met her in japan she one day
decided to accuse me of domestic
violence i would say it's alleged i
don't think it's real
but she used that as an excuse to take
the child to japan
this is actually a pretty big issue if
you're into
various circles
but you know japan is known as a black
hole for child abduction
so she took the kid it was uh
at the time it was devastating now i've
kind of pretty much moved forward with
that you know the show has to go on
right like i can't just uh
kind of like it's made me realize that
you need to focus on making the most of
your life no matter what and that
life is short so you have to enjoy it
right like there's certain things you
just can't go up against like it's not
worth fighting necessarily we can talk
about this a little bit more but then
yeah after that i i mean during this
time i also did work at uh google uh
tech lead there uh you know and then i
went over to facebook also working as a
tech lead over there some people at
facebook think i'm not a real tech lead
but i mean this is why i have to keep
telling people i am an ex google x med
attack lead
so facebook was doing six hundred
thousand dollars in income over there
actually one day they decided to fire me
for running a youtube channel and
yeah ever since then i've been running
this youtube channel uh you can check it
out tech lead but i essentially ran out
of content like two or three years ago i
don't know what people are still there
on the channel for it's probably loaded
with crypto trading bots just trying to
scam you but
uh maybe it's the only boss watching my
channel right now
this is 100
you know what i'm always curious how
many of our views are due to the bots
because as soon as i will post there's
always like there's always one who will
comment on every single post now they
could probably do that with one view
because it's the same account but i'm
curious there's got to be like at least
a few thousand views
are the bread and butter of my
uh monetization
strategy right it's like i i know a lot
of people say they don't want bots on
youtube but i need them for my ad
revenue you think they watch the ads
they probably add to the impression
counts on the ads and boost the revenue
yeah the craters yeah yeah
see look going back you mentioned that
japan was a black hole for child
abduction is that because they don't
have it because it's hard to track
people from the u.s to japan or is that
because they they don't have the
infrastructure to or the resources to to
track people or
why is the whole discussion unrelated to
finance perhaps but there is the idea
that japan believes in single custody of
children right and and they typically
have the situation where the
uh the mother watches the child the
husband goes to work all day
and barely shows up at home and if
there's a separation
the mother
oftentimes will get the child single
cause of the the father never sees the
child again and that's just the system
that they go with and what happens is
um
it's just maybe my personal point of
view but
uh
there's kind of this
princess psychology uh like a lot of
japanese women tend to grow up as little
princesses in in my personal view
there's a lot of immaturity involved in
this so when there's conflict
there's not good conflict resolution and
there's no concept of
uh double
parenthood there
in my personal view i kind of made peace
with this because if you've ever seen a
woman give birth you'll know that it's
massively painful
and
you know it's like my view is if it if
somebody wants a child and they
they get like the woman should probably
get to say like i i kind of see how
single custody
uh if anybody gets to decide maybe it
should be the mother right because like
if you ask me would i like to push a
watermelon through my body and then say
this is half somebody else's i would say
like that's not a clean deal like
maybe it should just belong to this
person
so yeah that i mean as far as
enforcement goes the more you pursue
somebody the deeper into hiding that
they go
there are things like the hague
convention which
are very difficult to enforce people try
to pursue this it costs
uh i know people who have spent like 250
000
uh i've met these people on trend to get
their children back
their entire communities and this
happens i mean this happens everywhere
in divorce as well like all of these
situations you can plow
hundreds of thousands of dollars into
this
and
you still may not get the result you're
looking for and the only people that win
oftentimes are going to be attorney the
attorneys the lawyers
so
i mean there was even this guy he made
the headlines a while ago he was
starving himself to try to get his child
back in japan this guy was
like a finance manager vincent vitro and
like these people are all many of them
are very well to do but
to me
it's not worth
like you have to pick your battles in
life right and
to me it's like this open world game
and there's some bosses on the map that
are just you can spend a lifetime
fighting for like you can spend you can
throw your whole life trying to defeat
this boss and maybe you're gonna win or
you can go
explore all the other fun parts in life
so even though yes i can go throw
hundreds of thousands of dollars into
this hay convention and hire all these
attorneys
and take this very aggressive attitude
i think it's better to just say i'm
going to go continue to enjoy my life as
best as i can make the most of it in the
short time that i have
and take a more gentle approach which is
typically like
like this is a problem with western
culture is that we believe in
litigation and we believe in
confrontation and aggression
and getting our way fighting for it and
that is victory
but
i would say you if you can find the an
approach that is more gentle and reaches
compromise
that's going to be more ideal so my
approach these days is really more more
towards compromise and just
understanding that people are like
totally insane sometimes and irrational
yeah
um
and to just
treat everybody like rabbit dogs like
people are not rational so you just have
to try to manage as best as you can i
can try to fight this person and
confront them and reason about them or i
can just say let me just give you what
you want right like let me just handle
this situation as as carefully as i can
without trying to provoke this other
person more
[Music]
interesting but first we gotta thank our
sponsor ftxus ftx is the most complete
crypto and finance app out there it
allows you to buy both crypto and nfts
with absolutely no fees you might have
heard of fdx through their partnerships
with steph curry tom brady and the miami
heat arena ftx is one of the largest
cryptocurrency exchanges in the world in
terms of daily users and trading volume
and they have a valuation of eight
billion dollars and their founder sam
bakeman freed plans to give away 99 of
what he personally makes to charities
most crypto exchanges charge two to
three dollar fees for every transaction
but with the ftx app you can trade as
many times as you want and it's all free
they also make dollar cost averaging
really easy with things like recurring
buys where they can pull money directly
from your bank account on a weekly
bi-weekly or monthly basis and invest it
for you automatically they even offer a
crypto friendly debit card allowing you
to spend crypto at millions of merchants
worldwide to start trading crypto and
nfts with no fees today with the link
down below in the description on the ftx
app again the link is down below in the
description to get started today with no
fees thank you so much ftx for
sponsoring this episode and back to the
podcast so you've kind of just accepted
the situation for what it is
and done your thing yeah i think some
things like i just don't want to throw
resources time and effort into into
fighting right like
it's just uh
if if the mother
wants the child to grow up without the
father
that's her choice
and and i think that she does
have priority the law may say there's 50
50 ownership
but if there were no law
by nature
the mother has
has priority
that's what i would say yeah and also
through the divorce
what were the finances like through
divorce because i know especially for
high earners
uh the results can be pretty uh
yeah controversy and you when did you
become a millionaire i think it was 25
24 right we we talked about this on the
early episode of the graham stefan
i mean i've been a millionaire since age
25 so i've lived with wealth
quite a while when were you a
millionaire 26. all right see that's how
far ahead i am with you and it compounds
by the way too
so it's like it's just the distance it's
going yeah yeah
um
i'm not going to ask your net worth
which maybe do it you can ask it now i'm
so upfront about it i made a video about
it it's 15 and a half you didn't ask but
that's that's what it is what's yours
check ether scan i mean i was worth like
20 million dollars on ether so yeah
check that out paper gains right there
and i can i can probably mint another uh
200 million if i want to
it's like simple just make a coin like
that um what were we talking about uh
you you're you're the wealth that you've
built up in your 20s how do you how you
did that and then what happened in in a
divorce this is how you get messed up in
in family court right like whatever
amount that you offer you can say
i'm going to offer you
5 000 child support a million dollars in
total finances
the other person does not know what is
fair
right so because they have no
understanding of what is fair by the
legal system they're going to say give
me
more
it's always going to be more until the
other person gets to a point where they
may really until an attorney comes and
the judge says this is fair but that
makes mediation incredibly difficult in
my opinion
and what happens if you're a higher
earner is that if you go talk to an
attorney they will
they'll just charge you through the roof
on everything
so
like
i tried to do everything myself because
i don't want any funds to go to the
attorneys
um if at all possible but if if the
other person is
there come situations where like the
other person can try to get you to pay
their attorney fees so you're paying
double attorney fees and attorneys can
cost
800 bucks an hour if if if it's a good
one so you could be paying 1600
per hour in the worst case possibly
maybe but what happens is like i
probably spent 25 30 000 on an attorney
and
they didn't even get me through a single
trial right it was only paperwork up to
that point so i i fired the attorney and
just said i'm going to just
represent myself in trial go in and i
just lost
and
you know like i went in there and i said
this is a kidnapping this person's
taking the child you know this is unfair
and they're just like cool
so so let's let's have you pay and
i think that's just the norm for family
court
even if she's in another country and you
have zero custody even if she's in
another country can absolutely nobody it
doesn't matter that's just the way
family court is now the california
family courts because you're respecting
all western courts
yeah i think because number one child
support has nothing to do with custody
so it's simply based on like
we we don't care what happened if we
don't know like even if this was a
kidnapping whatever like you pay
it's just as simple as that
the divorce is
the divorce is still going on quite
frankly so th this is going to be
another uh it's going to be another
headache how did you build your wealth
to begin with so i think this is
something valuable for people to
understand but my wealth was built over
probably
five six seven different
projects over my
uh career right it's not a single thing
and these took
many years so it's
it's really the personality that you
have and that determination and
persistence to keep doing success after
success after success in my personal
opinion that's going to get you to a
successful position right so like
probably my first
million was made from making a bunch of
apps on my own right like facebook apps
facebook gaming right when that took off
but that only got me to 1 million or so
less than that you know i probably had
to create three different social gaming
apps taking advantage of the the whole
app trend on facebook twitter apps and
all that to
get to
that stage but
that's not enough to retire on that's
why i went back to work many later on
and you know like there was the whole
google facebook career episode i had
that made me some more money here and
there i had episodes where i had to
learn stock trading right because after
a while your investments take over if
you make money but you don't learn
investments
uh you're going to be limited right like
like there could be massive gains there
that you don't pick up on
after that then maybe there's the whole
youtube section right segment which
helps make more money but if all i did
was youtube
i would not have monetized as much as
maybe if i were able to create
additional content and courses and
continue to
pivot the channel to stay relevant
to just keep keep the clickbait farm
coming along right so you know you see a
lot of other people they're making their
youtube channel maybe they make one
channel that's all they do
it fades out
they go back to work right and so i
would say what the thing about me is i
kept reinventing myself and kept finding
new opportunities
so it's not like
this is why when people say oh you're
just lucky
well i got lucky like
seven times ten times in a row right
like
these are adventures multiple ventures
not just one
and many people have trouble even doing
a single venture right and in their
entire life
they don't ever get off the rails i'm a
little confused on the story line here
so this is i'm assuming
just after college or was this while you
were in college when you started
developing apps yeah so the apps
business was done uh
right after i finished grad school
but before you started working it wasn't
microsoft yeah so it was in 2007
facebook was booming uh people were
making lots of money on the facebook
apps everything was going viral right so
i i actually
had to teach myself a php javascript
well
it was hellish you know like
full stack web development server
management um this is not something that
any college is going to teach you right
like nobody teaches you this stuff you
just have to go learn by yourself
so that's what i did why that
did you just spot an opportunity how do
you come up with the idea so i
i think i'm personally attracted to
whatever is just interesting or cool or
trendy at the time right like
uh this was just a very interesting
trendy technology you know like the
whole facebook apps thing you can make
massive impact and maybe it's impact for
me that i've been attracted to it's like
anything that can
that looks like yeah it can just make
impact on the world right um the
facebook apps
was ability the ability to reach massive
amounts of people you could kind of say
the same with the whole youtube thing
when i when i saw youtube
probably when you saw it too
many people were not taking it seriously
right it was
it was like if you were doing youtube
people would laugh at you
right people would say
oh professionals don't do that nowadays
you see venture capitalists and
entrepreneurs and like
loads of professional people on youtube
trying to build their audience but
they're way too late
so
you know there's the what there's the
followers and the leaders tech lead like
me
but you know it's like if you're
attracted to impact
then i think you may have what it takes
there's many people who come to me and
say
they are attracted to code they love
coding
that's not right
right code is a tool to achieve impact
it's a it's a tool to achieve massive
scalability
uh at low cost to reach it right like
massive amounts of people and deliver
value but
code is not the draw it's never been the
draw it is the product that impact that
i've always been seeking so i just learn
whatever technology is necessary like
when i was working at google and
facebook it was through
ios development
ios is completely different
tech stack than full stack web
development a completely different
technology so i switched right away to
just whichever technology is going to be
necessary youtube
in my mind youtube is also another
different tech stack right like it's a
whole set of skills that you need and so
when people come and say they just want
to learn to code
it's like
if all you do is learn how to code
what you're really looking at is a 30k
job low income in the outsource facility
center
uh where you're at the computer 12 hours
a day for 10 years straight that's
coding
i don't think anybody really wants to do
that but you see so many people say oh
my dream is to become a software
engineer there's plenty of software
engineers like the linux programmers who
just sit in their basements and never
achieve anything with their lives and
make zero impact upon the world
those are the people
i've never envied
who we envy are
myself
jeff bezos elon musk mark zuckerberg
bill gates steve jobs and myself and the
people who make the impact right yeah
these people were not just programmers
they they were entrepreneurs but first i
want to thank our sponsor grammarly so
guys it's already april but i feel like
the years just started i've been
spending way too much time writing and
perfecting emails well jack if you want
to save time writing emails just install
grammarly grammarly is an all-in-one
writing tool that helps you communicate
clearly and effectively even when you're
short on time grammarly is like having a
professional writer look through your
work 24 7. and their free version is
also amazing since it protects you from
things like basic spelling grammar
phrasing and punctuation but the real
magic happens when you upgrade to
grammarly premium grammarly premium
offers clarity suggestions and even full
sentence rewrites to help you clearly
convey your message and avoid
miscommunication are you trying to
impress girls with your stupendous
writing ability we know you are well
grammarly's built-in tone detector can
help you sound as confident professional
or as formal as you need and they also
provide vocab suggestions which help you
replace overused words phrases and also
words you really need grammarly premium
man so get through those emails and your
work quicker by keeping it concise
confident and effective with grammarly
so visit grammarly.com
iced coffee today and sign up for a free
account and when you're ready to upgrade
to grammarly premium you can get 20 off
just for being a listener again guys
that's 20 off at grammarly
g-r-a-m-m-a-r-o-y
dot com slash iced coffee thanks so much
grammarly and back to the podcast how
much were you making on the app at its
peak
because you must do yeah you're 24 25
years old yeah i mean
the so the first app i i built is it was
a social gaming app uh probably was
about a million per year type of thing
total yeah there were some apps that
were doing uh 20 000 per day
actually so like
but these apps can be short-lived things
other apps would do
five thousand dollars per day
but the thing that people don't
understand is even though i had
say three four highly successful apps
there were
50 apps i built
probably that were not successful that
nobody heard about
right
so
you know
one lesson i did learn i remember was uh
in my younger years uh entrepreneur told
me you need to fail three times before
you before you find your first success
what do you think about that i don't
know if i've really failed at
i wouldn't call that necessarily a
failure but but it's like you have to
have three failures to have one success
unless you count to failure like
don't want to see open houses
for you it was the very first youtube
channel you started it was just
instantaneous yeah everything i've done
it's usually done well but but i've
never gone into anything i've done for
the money it's always been i do
something because i really enjoy it and
it happens to make money like uh like
what started off as taking pictures for
reef aquariums for fun turned into a
turned into a job that then turned into
this whole passion throughout high
school right just make money uh same
with real estate it's like i i did a
quick job before that that i thought i
wanted to go on investment banking so i
got a job at a precious metals
investment firm i hated the job but it
was really good experience um
but even as an agent it's like i just
wanted to like i wanted to work for free
honestly and it turned into a great
career and then youtube was something
like i would do that for free it turned
into a great career
um i would say even for youtube you have
videos that perform poorly right they
get 10 out of 10. yeah and
and some that maybe after you do
a series of poor videos you get a one
out of ten right so like
you can even consider some of some of
these videos to have been sort of
somewhat failure no i think it depends
how you frame it because some people are
like oh i failed at this this sucks i
i'm a
you know i'm worthless but i've always
viewed every failure as like why did i
fail why did he so i guess
i i frame any failure as like oh i
learned something good so it's never
been a failure for me because if if
there is something that doesn't work i'm
like oh what can i do how could i do
that differently oh i learned a really
good lesson from this here's how i'm
going to make it better in that so like
that's it's almost like a step up i
think that's a good point yeah because
like even for me
maybe i made 50 apps even i don't
consider those to be
failures right it's like maybe i made an
app and i learned something or i got a
few hundred bucks from it and so
a lot of people say
well being an entrepreneur is so risky
because you may fail
i don't think these people fail right
like they they probably make a few
hundred few thousand dollars from their
venture they learn something and they
move on and they satisfy their curiosity
so even for them they not they may not
picture it as a pure failure yeah i
think it just depends on how you frame
it and there's uh
what what is it called i read i read a
uh a book on this or it was like an
audio book about like um
a self-fulfilling prophecy that when you
get in the when you start doing well at
something it it
spirals into another thing into another
thing because you have that
self-fulfilling belief that if you do
something you're going to do well at it
and because of that you shift your
mindset to do well at that because you
believe in it yeah versus other people
get caught in the mindset of like oh i
suck at this let me give it a shot and
it's probably not going to do well but
let me try and it doesn't do well it's
like oh man
i suck at this i i can't do this and
that continues that influences the next
choices yeah so this is something
this is a theory i have that plays into
this which is you know how
love
cannot be negotiated right desire cannot
be negotiated you cannot rationalize
somebody to
love you right it's like
you can't sit down and have a
conversation and say like here are the
top 10 reasons why you should love me
it's just
if the person wants it they will
rationalize to themselves all your good
traits and if they don't want it they
will convince themselves that
you're a terrible person
right
so
in a sense i it's like we are where we
are because
we
we chose that place that we wanted to be
and then self-rationalize ourselves into
that
um
and it's kind of like how you people
also say i don't have time for this
no you didn't
you have time right you didn't want to
make time it wasn't a priority in your
life and so therefore
you decided not to create the time for
and you made these excuses
so i tend to believe like
um
all of us are exactly where we want to
be no i think all of us are where we
we think
we're at where we deserve or we're at
what we
believe to be our own limit
that's what i kind of think because i
don't think any anybody could look at
not anybody could look at their life but
i think a lot of people would look at
their life and say i'm not necessarily
happy but i didn't want to be here i
want to be over there but i think deep
down maybe it's they they are where they
are because
they uh they feel like that's what they
that's what they they deserve or like
that's what i'm worth is this
it's like we
many people are addicted to their own
struggle their own self misery right
like somebody may say i want to i want
to be a book author and that's the state
of mind that they stay in and they never
write a book
right and i think we kind of push
ourselves into these limiting areas and
there's this there's this other book i
read called the courage to be disliked
it's a pretty interesting one but it's
based on the idea of um so like young
psychology basically says that we are a
product of our past right so they say if
you had trauma when you were a kid
then
for example you can never have a family
a happy family life because you had this
trauma as a kid and so therefore your
future is predetermined
but there's also this idea that trauma
doesn't exist
okay so it's like if you're here and
you just will yourself to be happy
uh you can be a happy person right your
point in time you're not necessarily the
result of prior action
so anyone can just say
i'm happy
and
what like i'm suddenly i'm happy right
and you can let go of that prior
identity
that you may have had
so based on that idea it's like you can
choose where you want to be kind of like
say to yourself if you want to be a
happy like if you just want to say i'm a
happy person uh the things in my life
i'm going to view with a certain
perspective as being that of success
then
say right like maybe these were good
things right like some people say to
themselves
i had a bad day
maybe you had a wonderful day
right you're not in jail
all right like you're not dead
you're doing fantastic
and then other people may just
characterize that as something bad yeah
it's weird i always view things as it
could be worse and i try my best even
even if i have a bad day i'm like well
at least this didn't happen well that
could have happened it didn't yeah do
you or i try to think you know how how
could this be better and am i going to
what how was today for you terrible
today was could have been worse it could
yes today was the worst day i've had in
probably a year
maybe sorry about that yeah or maybe two
years this is probably been the most
yeah this is the worst day yeah
basically my aquarium sprung a leak and
that's like every aquarium owner's worst
nightmare is the seam of the tank just
all of a sudden bust so i woke up this
morning with 40 gallons
this is why minimalism is what you need
you're a slave to your possessions right
you're a slave to your aquarium no but i
love the aquarium the the aquarium is
the one thing that brings me so much
yeah
so much happiness
you're an emotional slave to your things
right but i think graham actually likes
people like you mentioned people are
generally where like wherever they are
they're at their happiest because they
made their own choices to put themselves
there right and graham may be a slave to
some material things such as his
aquarium such as his zenith el primero
oh but i'm not a slave to that but
aquarium yes but i think that that's
kind of what fuels him he's a very
interesting person insofar as like he's
very fueled by like stress and like
negative emotion oh gosh i don't have
negative emotions this is
have you done like a personality trait
like there's a trait in the ocean yeah
analysis for and
neuroticism
so that's the
tendency to over worry or to over stress
i don't know i'm happy to take it and
see and see what come up for me what's
your mbti do you know that what is that
myers-briggs oh i
and i don't know i intj or something
something like that
i'm not really sure cool all right but
yeah but the aquarium is like i was
unhappy with ethiopia because i really
wanted an aquarium and i did that was
years of just like looking forward to
getting the aquarium and i get the
aquarium and it leaks
but i'll get a new one you still got an
aquarium i still got an aquarium and
i'll get a new one in three weeks so i
can set up so now i'm thinking like okay
what's the what's the bride said well
the tank didn't explode wasn't it still
safe everything is still safe and i get
a new tank what's the downside well it's
it's a day it's it's basically two days
of my time that's the downside is it two
days one day is going to be very
memorable of cleaning up the all the
water the next day is going to be
transferring it to a new tank with and
i'll put sand in this tank this time
didn't put sand before i'll make it
better
so i i try to do everything like that if
something bad happens like how do you
practice gratitude i sh i
did
you gotta get on the interview
yeah like we influencers have to
like have mindfulness practice gratitude
drink black coffee do you do
intermittent fasting no gotta get on
that man i mean otherwise you're not
legit as an influencer
uh yeah i gotta take cold showers too
wake up at four a.m to meditate yeah
yeah you got that i did i did practice
gratitude minimalism
where is that i couldn't do minimalism
really no why uh i think there's some of
that that that
i would enjoy temporarily but it's like
you're like
and that that fun and the challenge of
putting together something that uh
it's like the searching of putting
together a puzzle
like for me it would be a car collection
and like what cars can i buy well the
ford gt it would be a tesla road
if you cannot be happy with a cup of
coffee
you can never be happy
because your desire
will be limitless right like if you
temper your desires
uh
you can be happy with with anything
otherwise you're always going to be on
that hedonistic treadmill but see i'm
happy looking forward to stuff like like
i'm looking forward i want to test the
roadster you know i'm looking for yeah
sure there will always be something else
but like to me that's that's part of the
collection but if everything got
stripped away from you would you be able
to be happy uh yes but but i would be
happy with the expectation that i'd be
able to build that back
so you're not gonna be happy unless you
have this tesla roadster that's holding
you back i mean you're you've already
got plenty of cars right but it's but
but it's a part of the collection it's
like but but for me it's the fun of
picking a car that i think is a good
investment but you what if you can't buy
the car because you got stripped of
everything
then it's just the hopes of being able
to buy a car yeah i i
yeah i've always had the hope and the
and the belief that like well if i'm not
gonna do it now i'll be able to do it in
the future
this is the
the thing i've realized is investment is
is the most boring thing in the world
like i used to be into it just like you
but i'm i've like transcended transit
beyond that yeah
like
let's pretend that uh bitcoin is the
ultimate investment
let's pretend that it's just going to
outperform any other thing sure so then
would you just say
and and let's put so would you just say
okay let's just like
get rid of everything
put the all into bitcoin if you make
more money put it more into bitcoin
and
it's like just anything you get you're
just going to plow into crypto some type
of cryptocurrency no because now i've
valued more so my time so i'm like i'm
doing things now that would save me time
and for convenience
um so like i do see it more of a value
in that
but as far as the car i mean the car is
something you could enjoy so the car is
part of something that like you could go
and stare at it it's like a piece can't
you just rent a car like here's the
here's the experience that changed me is
have you ever driven like a lamborghini
yeah huracan
like
i went to this race course you can do
one in las vegas drove a lamborghini
huracan next to like a
aston martin
and
you know there were gtrs and like
ferraris and everybody just said yeah
the lamborghini and ferrari are in a
totally different class and just
like the other cars just look like pure
trash compared to like the lambos
and after driving that for me i just
thought
um i have
absolutely no desire to own
like a gtr which i used to want to own
um
because it's just total trash and you
know other cars you're playing the stat
this game like people say aldi is the
car for uh
basically like poor wealthy people right
people who are trying to show status are
actually poor people right like if you
want to actually show status
uh get a classless car so for me
like which cars have no class mini
coopers tesla's gosh mini cooper and
audis yeah i mean like let's say tesla
too yeah they're saying all of macy and
graham's car
yeah and volvos yeah yeah
i'm pretty up there i mean you guys
don't have to compare yourself you have
transcended everything and everyone yeah
and everything life experiences you know
like
let's talk about life experiences which
like have you been out of the country
yes
but never out of the continent so you've
been to like canada
canada mexico is right
when i was your age
i had already been how old are you like
late 30s but i i say to myself early 40s
just just to give me he's transcended
beyond his actual actually how can i
dance like you hear jack like what is
age anyways
it's a technique doesn't have an a
technically just i use like the
lunar calendar yeah he lives in the
moment yeah he is how old he thinks he
is
age is just a mindset jack like when i
was your age yeah
i studied abroad in japan you know i had
already been to like angkor wat cambodia
vietnam halong bay thailand multiple
times
sailing in the caribbean like
it's beautiful you rent a catamaran for
like a week you go sell it in the
bahamas in the british virgin islands i
went selling in thailand you know i had
already lived in
have you been to hawaii yeah you went to
hawaii i had already lived in
london you know the uk i spent time
traveling through all of going from like
the swiss alps down through the uh
french coast right into the southern
spain area
i've been to iceland right like done all
of these things and
you're like here reading news right like
you're reading a bunch of news and
making video about news in order to buy
more bitcoin like paper wealth to invest
that into more paper wealth
for me i realized i was like
i just think this is time that you're
not going to necessarily get back what
are your assets
health wealth time and
youth youth is
important right because if you go
if you go traveling when you're 40 or 50
or if you're driving in a porsche when
you're 40 or 50 nobody cares about that
and your experience will be totally
different
than if you do it
you know now
and
arguably
since i made my wealth early i
recognized
everybody gets wealthy everybody becomes
a millionaire by the time they're
60 70. right like it's very simple you
work 30 years
for
30k
that gets you what a million bucks so
the advantage that you have is your time
people want that money now in order to
experience it and use it
and i don't think it would
like this is something you're going to
realize when it's too late maybe
but
you're going to say lose the next five
ten years of your life
and then you're going to say okay i made
another uh
one million dollars
what happened
you made five million but then you lost
4 million in the market crash
so or right or you may have made some
money you lost a bunch in the market
crash
and then uh and then you got divorced or
whatever right like something somebody
sues you and then you break your leg
and what happened right that was it
maybe you get cancer
so
people often say like you have to enjoy
your journey the destination is going to
be trash
like in many ways life is a car crash in
slow motion the ending we all die
we are we all just die
so
in my opinion like
you create the lifestyle that you want
and you you need to live that
and
the lifestyle needs to
use money
right because
many people i think they
they go through life they make money and
they want to live the fire dream right
financial independence dream where
they're
they're essentially just burning very
little amounts of their money and
they're just living at home watching tv
and they take two vacation trips a year
this is something that you're born with
right like when you were a kid
your parents already gave you that life
right like you just go live with your
parents if that's what you want
you can go you can play your video games
you don't have to work and your parents
can take you on like a vacation twice a
year or something like that right like
it's extremely boring i would say this
financial independence route
fat fire is one where you're able to
live a little bit more
but these people still end up with
multiple millions right and in their
bank account when they die and then they
never truly
they never truly find the use for that
money
you know and and it's kind of saddening
and extremely boring especially now that
we have cryptocurrency
where you just say
if you get money just put it into uh
into this uh digital dashboard right
that's what we're all doing make money
put into a digital dashboard number go
up
that's it keep doing that and then
10 years past 20 years pass
so in my opinion saving money and
investing money
is like living on autopilot
it is the most boring and lazy path
and if you're able to actually figure
out how do you deploy cash right
spending money is difficult
it's extremely difficult to spend money
and deploy it into a way that achieves
enjoyment for you you can go buy
a
rolex i don't know if that
gives you much joy
especially
right like you buy it you put it in a in
a cabinet in a drawer somewhere and you
say okay this is a nice investment
and and you don't really look at it so
much i i guess you two on the rolexes
see yeah here's the thing though for me
it's like i think a lot of people enjoy
what they do and they would be doing it
regardless so for me it's like
i i don't i don't know right now i i
would enjoy vacations like that like to
me that just sounds
i'd rather just like what sounds great
to me is a free schedule over the next
week get to work if you if you could
pause time right now though and there
was no expectation of you posting the
algorithm would stop yeah how would you
spend that time
gosh i don't know i probably want to get
ahead i mean sure yeah like
that would make me feel good i have
family friends who say like
um they're doing extremely well i mean
we all have friends like this they're
doing extremely well and they're still
working in their 60s or 70s and they say
oh i love my job i would never quit
because i wouldn't know what i would do
with my time
it's extremely lazy isn't it right like
these people are on autopilot
they followed the path laid out to them
by society
to
uh do their nine to five
and to not think further than that
when
there's a whole world waiting for them
and and you have to actually
it takes extremely amount
like a lot of time and effort to figure
out
what you want to do like what i think
about is
um an itinerary like when you take a
vacation trip you need
to spend maybe uh two weeks planning the
itinerary you need to actually sit down
and put in time and effort and research
this like what are you gonna do
uh if you don't have an attorney and you
never put in the time and effort to
think about what you want to do
then you just say well
i wouldn't know what i would do it's too
hard
i guess i'm just going to keep working
because i can make five bucks an hour if
i do this you're going to reach a point
in your life you may have already
reached it where your investments
the returns on your investments will
outpace any active income that you as an
individual is able to generate
right like
um and at that point
why do you work
you can increase your like let's say fun
i enjoy it like i don't know i love
doing like this this is kind of work but
like i would be doing this regardless
and and i've even thought like what
would i do if i took you know a full
week off won't work like i i would be
loading up podcasts i would do more
podcast guests i do more reactions on
the second channel i would just keep
doing what i'm doing yeah probably for
you this is absolutely the position you
should be in
let's say you're
10 years older
oh it's yeah i know it's going to change
let's say let's say you're 10 years
older now
uh would you is your answer still the
same probably not but
i would but i would have the options to
do
at that time or it could be in a month i
mean realistically it'll probably be two
to five years that's what you know kind
of
and at that point i could
re-evaluate the schedule and kind of
maybe figure out something different but
i see probably two to five years like i
love this and maybe if it's longer it's
longer if it's less
i've i've always just done like what i
felt
in my gut it's just like this is what i
want to do i'm just gonna do that and
that's the right choice it's always been
there i have a question for you yeah um
if you knew you were going to be gone
one week from now what would you do if i
were going to be gone yeah i i don't
want to say it oh youtube algorithm i
would be unalive yes
in one week what would you do
oh gosh um
i would probably go scuba diving in fiji
with with with macy with everybody i
would take everybody i could
yeah i wouldn't you two i would probably
take 30 people to fiji uh to go scuba
diving and then i'd find a way to divide
up my money so that so that it goes to
the right people you're such a great guy
jack who's saying i'm not going to yeah
why are you just hey what i didn't say
anything
it goes to ramsay and bailey oh okay the
the ramsay and bailey foundation
they're gonna have this huge house in
bel air yeah it's gonna be so nice let's
say like
let's say um
you make a video you get no views and
you get no money do you still make
videos
certainly not
huh what but there's there's because
like
there's two things that feed you number
one is uh your own ego right by getting
the views
you feel self-important right like hey
guys everybody's watching me the second
thing is maybe maybe money the money is
going to get to a point where
and you may already be at this where
it's
it's money that like
like for me i'm gonna die with money in
the bank account
right i i'm there's gonna be money in
the bank account when i die even if i
try to spend it
many people are going to get to that
point you're you're probably at that
point
um so the money is just kind of like
you can make it you're you're never
going to touch it in your entire life
and quite frankly your investments may
outpace your your active income by ten
to one i mean you know you may get to a
point
your own narcissism or ego is something
that you don't necessarily like if you
escape out of it and get out of the
status game
anyways like yeah but but i think it's
it's less about myself and more about
like what you provide to somebody else
and for me it's the it's the fulfillment
and purpose that i get when i see
someone come up and say hey it's because
of you that i bought a house it's
because of you that i got my first
credit card and i did this and now i'm
like now i'm financially secure and like
that's the sort of stuff for me that
really pushes me and and it helps that
money is a byproduct of that and like
obviously that that's a component of it
i enjoy that uh and that just as it
gives me more content to make yeah but
even something like this it's like
i would say there's a very small portion
of like ego and i would say the bigger
portion is that whoever's watching this
is able to get a different perspective
that they wouldn't have
without us being in this room together
and spending our times like talking
about stuff like this so i think that's
that's great
for me
since i'm
i'm basically like
i was where you were like
10 years ago or something it's like i
had my phase where i dedicated
a year or more of my life to reading
news every single day and day trading
uh i got nothing out of like the news i
read i'm not sure if i i attained any
skill out of right no long-term lasting
learnings no personal growth
i realized that all the news i was
reading every day was
i couldn't care less about it's like
jerome powell raised interest rates by
25
you know uh joe biden's doing something
they're printing this much some company
released some annual earnings report two
weeks later is that news important no
it's complete garbage right it's like
it's unactionable priced into the market
so
you do this long enough you do this
another five ten years you may get to a
point where you're just like
buy and hold you guys right if i want to
help you i tell you
a buy and hold deploy all your cash into
uh amazon apple google
s p 500
and just hold it
right and
uh and get like bitcoin or whatever
right get some crypto and that's it
just buy and hold don't sell
that's all you got to do right maybe
that's it and and then all the other
news that you're reading
is just
causing you to were around to spin and
you're just like
do i buy do i sell no just you already
deployed your capital so just hold on to
it yeah but some of that i think i enjoy
it i love the process of reading through
the news every day i love seeing what's
new and for me it's like
it's it's a component of that but both
entertainment because like i watch i
watch like every finance video that's
out there and i would say half of them
all i watched just for the information
and that's i just i wanted just the
details but the other half is
entertainment like i'll just sit there
and i'll like eat dinner or i'll eat
lunch and i'll watch a video and like
that's what i just
but i also acknowledge that i'm not
i'm kind of weird when it comes to that
sense that i i find like these very
specific
topics extremely interesting and i i
fixate on them and so for me it's like
the reef aquarium and business and
making money it's just like those are
the two segments that i
love i mean i would say i i still do pay
attention i i still read it as well but
it's just like
when you step back it's maybe the most
interesting thing of all the boring news
out there so it's still something to pay
attention to yeah that's interesting but
let's say for someone like that you know
if you're not you're not chasing
anything why
why do this why create
million token yeah million token check
it out milliontoken.org we got them you
guys we're on the graham stefan iced
coffee hour
check it out jack
jack yeah million token yeah one million
limited supply
so i had spent probably the last nine
months of my youtube channel really
promoting this right this token was
released in june in july of last year
uh initially it was i mean i mentioned
this before as well it's a joke right
it's like it was supposed to be this fun
social crypto activity because i'm a
programmer i know how to create how to
create some of these smart contracts
that it would be this community activity
we could just all get together and it
was going to be something that just
lasted one video really right like
uh was that really your expectation
though yeah really yeah it was like it
was going to be this fun activity show
you guys how i created the token how you
can create your own tokens and just put
it out there right and and it was
supposed to be this like i make apps all
the time right so to create a token like
i make programming projects on my
channel occasionally as well
so to me it was just like hey this is
kind of neat i didn't give it much more
thought than that and deployed it it
turns out over time that
uh the token has pretty good
fundamentals actually right it's like
one token backed by uh one usd coin
the rest is up to market fluctuations
and
there it actually had some legs to
continue running and the more i looked
at it and other people started getting
into it as well it's just like
th this is actually pretty neat right
like the fundamentals are actually
pretty good i mean i don't want to to my
own horn here but the fundamentals are
super clean because
it's like it's never been hacked it's
bridged across almost every blockchain
you know you've got ethereum binance
marching avalanche phantom harmony one
maybe some more
the zero inflation rate transaction
times are super fast you can use any
blockchain that suits you
right so it's like if you compare and a
smart contract compatible it supports
nfts
it supports like
all of the
capabilities of that so when you compare
to so here's the thing right like
bitcoin
and dogecoin are first-gen coins they
don't support smart contracts
right they don't have nft support they
don't have yeah
right aren't they working
they're still trying to deploy that
right like jack dorsey of twitter is
trying to come up with
uh
like smart contract support for bitcoin
still right like like they're trying to
work on some of this stuff
then you've got
the second gen coins which i would say
is like
um
maybe shiba inu or something like that
some some token that is purely on
ethereum ethereum gas fees aren't crazy
expensive and plus some of these coins
have pretty terrible fundamentals like
they may have inflation you don't know
who the founder of sheba coin is
it's like
you don't know how many coins like there
could be some shady stuff going on in
there
so when you take a look at a million at
least it's interesting because
it's on so many chains you can get super
low gas fees
and
like the founder is stoxed and it's it's
it's just kind of a name but why but why
create it just for fun was it was it at
a boredom was it just
why why put your time into that when you
could be traveling
or doing something else i tend to so
again i believe in like what the journey
right it's like whatever's neat whatever
is interesting maybe it's like an art
project or something right so i i make
apps out there all the time whatever i
think is just kind of interesting so
that's
it's really like
it's game theory it's a social
experiment right it's like if if i put
out a token
backed by one usd coin one interesting
thing about this is it will never
disappear
right the project will never lose value
it won't
just vanish because there's always value
attached to it
so and then any price above that is
simply market dynamics
right so
it's like what would happen to this it's
also pretty cool because like it's an
nft it's a hybrid nft right it's like um
right it's like it's it's a fun badge
for anybody at least on my channel like
as a millionaire
if you also want to be a millionaire you
can own like a million tokens so like
there's some pretty fun things with that
it didn't take too long to deploy and i
always wanted to
way to go bailey for lightening the mood
here i always wanted to just try out the
smart contract so yeah that's
what happened with coffeezilla
we we saw some big this was the biggest
drama of youtube back then when this
came out
coffee's elevated video yeah so
unfortunately
here's the thing
when coffeezilla
initially messaged me um he was intent
to just like he builds his reputation on
destroying as many
he just wants to call everything a scam
that's how he gets his views if he came
and said
this project is pretty neat actually
there's some things i like about it hey
crypto's kind of cool you guys
he's going to alienate his audience
right he builds his life on criticizing
other people
like what value to add but when he came
to me he said i i want to destroy your
token value basically like i i want to
just comment and make this video that
you're scam and i'm just like
there's a lot of people who are holding
on to this and
like
i want i i don't think develop i don't
think you should just go and like trash
these people's values right you're not
hurting me you're hurting these people
i'm trying to protect my community but
he just wanted to make any claim that he
can so he comes up and makes up this
claim that
really has no basis but what he's saying
is um he particularly lashed on to this
thing about liquidity okay so where he
says
i put a million dollar i said i put a
million dollars of my own money into
million token
and he says well did you really when
actually the way i deployed it was
i put 50 000
uh
liquidity with 50 000 of tok d tokens
right this is just a way that uniswap
works but
here's my original thinking
right i was going to say
i have a million of these tokens supply
i'm going to
i i actually like through coinbase i
can't just bring in a million dollars
right away they have all these
restrictions and account limitations so
i'm able to bring in 50 000 and deploy
match that with 50 000 tokens and deploy
that but originally i was going to say
why don't i
deploy these tokens over time
uh i'll release 50 000 tokens and back
each one with 50 dollars
right so the backing is there
when those are sold out i'll release
another fifty thousand and set a buy
floor for another fifty thousand right
so i will set these buy floors
and just put in the buy order for fifty
000 at the time now if you have 50 000
and i'm not that familiar with it let's
if you've just released 50 000 wouldn't
that mean less liquidity meaning there's
more volatility in the price to go up
because there's fewer being released so
at this point i did not even understand
liquidity right like i didn't all i knew
was i can create a token i want to
figure out how to get it deployed
i i even imagined in my head that i can
set by floors right so i can deploy
fifty thousand set fifty thousand by
floor deploy another 50k put another
that's like yeah
so what's a buy floor is that is that is
a market order right a market limit
order to buy
you know like 50 000 tokens at one
usdc okay
it turns out that
in
the decentralized exchanges you cannot
set i mean this is getting into the
weeds right like you cannot set
uh market orders for buy and sell
there is no buy and sell order actually
what you're doing is you're doing a swap
and you're interacting with liquidity
pools
so
because of the way this works
essentially like you need to
deploy the liquid
you basically
need to match up the number of tokens
with the
the liquidity that you put in and
you just put that out anyway so so but
there's no way that you could set a
minimum be like i'm gonna put 50 000 out
there but the minimum price i want for
these 50 is two dollars yeah you cannot
set uh limit orders like that so this
was something that i mean at the time
but you couldn't but don't you have to
to guarantee that it's a dollar
doesn't there have to be a limit order
to be like well i'm not going to sell
this below a dollar so
at the time unit swap v3 which is
concentrated like capital efficiency
liquidity pools is this complicated uh
concept um it just came out
people were still figuring out how it
works
um
i was able to
over time i realized that i can use the
v3 pools to set a liquidity wall
at one usdc for one million token and so
now there is you can check even there's
a million dollar liquidity wall
for
uh
one million dollars worth of usdc for
every token so that backs each token but
yeah
even now like
it's excess you could even say it's
excessive right because if i
if i release 50 000 tokens
and i have
a million dollars liquidity while that's
like you don't need that much capital
backing
whatever you release
right so but isn't there a chance that
let's say a 100 000 people want to sell
at the same time there's only 50 000 in
the liquidity pool what would is that is
that possible that
more people can sell than than liquid
no not not if you monitor not if you
so again you have to keep track of how
many tokens are
in the free market
if there's like 10 tokens floating
around
you only need
a liquidity wall of 10 right 10 usdc
coins
to back all of those right so
essentially the like every token was
always and has always been backed yeah
right by the one usdc peg
and
coffeezilla is simply
i think he was simply just saying like
hey
you
only put in 50 000 at first right and
and this
and then like as the
basically as people exchange usdc coin 4
million token
there were more mil there were more usdc
coins that i figured out hey you know
what rather than waiting for a coin base
to bring in more funds to deploy
uh
since people were exchanging one for one
the usdc can actually be used to deploy
more tokens and
in either case right they would always
all be back now for but how many
do you hold on to because i mean and
again i'm not familiar with this but
let's just say you hold on to 900 000 so
there's only 100 thousand for sale
doesn't that mean a smaller float
essentially means that the price could
go up higher if more people are buying a
smaller amount like with gamestop the
reason it went up so high was because a
lot of those were were held and there
wasn't a lot on the market so because
there weren't a lot if people were
buying was driving up the price higher
couldn't that be a component yeah so
i i think this was probably one thing
that i i wish i could have done earlier
was to deploy more of the tokens faster
given like again this was something i
was not
super familiar with but the whole
liquidity thing i learned over time but
like i did not think
like i i deployed with 50 000 you know
and within the next day i think i
deployed another 50 000.
so but i was thinking
how much are people gonna buy right like
maybe
5 000 tokens so in my mind
50k was just like
excessive but i was just thinking you
know what this this is the limit i can
bring in
um and i i deployed the tokens pretty
much as quickly as i could
you know to people who wanted it yeah
uh could you disclose how many you have
now
yeah you i mean you can totally check on
the ether scan i own
uh 60 about six percent basically of the
million tokens which is from a
distribution standpoint this is what you
want like you want you don't want whales
in the community so
this is like i mean
at first we had some people who just by
come in they recognize hey this is an
opportunity
they they kind of knew like
their game around the cryptocurrency so
they bought a whole bunch they were
whales
and they were able to like
like the whales are very dangerous in
the community like i see people
sometimes
in the past
they would be holding on to massive
amounts of tokens i would just be
thinking when are they going to sell
this
um
if you check the distribution now it's
like
we there's no whales it's it's a very
nice distribution when you take a look
at dogecoin yeah do you know like 50 of
all those coins are held by like
10 wallets or something like that
right so like
it's like these these 10 people or so
can crash
dogecoin if they wanted to get out now i
am curious though because you went from
100 ownership
with a million dollars down to six
doesn't that mean that to give up your
ownership you you've been selling coins
along the way at whatever price
someone's willing to pay because you
provide the million but if someone says
i'm willing to spend twenty dollars for
every one that has to come not from
you right
no it's
so i don't
to understand liquidity you like if i
were to sell i sell to myself if i'm the
liquid i'm the primary liquidity
provider i can right like you trade
against the liquidity pool
if you create the liquidity pool and you
buy and sell you you're trading against
yourself so i think this is one thing
some people don't understand it's like
you
it's
it's actually i think it's actually
difficult to try to so-called rock pool
project because if you sell yourself you
just sell it back to yourself
so what i do is uh i i provide the i
create the liquidity pools and
the liquidity pools were a way for
people to just
um
the tokens essentially get deployed as
the
as their spine pressure all right right
but the price
deploying the liquidity pool is
generally a neutral position
and it it never causes the price to go
down but yeah i guess my question is
let's say you you deploy 50 000 at a
dollar
the price gets bit up to two dollars
let's just say and you said now i need
to provide more liquidity so
i'm gonna give another 50 000
tokens but the price is two dollars now
by you giving up that 50 000 tokens does
that now mean that you
in return get a hundred thousand dollars
because you gave
five percent of your liquidity because
you would because you wouldn't sell it
for less than what people are willing to
pay because then that would be unfair to
the people who bought the first 50 000
so you have to match
the market value
so wouldn't that mean that you went from
100 ownership
and would release the liquidity at
whatever price it's trading at
uh i
so i think it's important to recognize
you can lose money on liquidity yes okay
so like let's say the price is 200 and
you deploy a liquidity pool that's an
agreement to not only sell tokens at a
price of 200 but an agreement to buy
them back at 200 as well
so so if if you think the market has
gone ahead of itself like let's say it's
just there's a lot of hype and
speculation
and you deploy liquidity you're buying
you could be buying a bunch of the
tokens
and
if the token right you'll be buying them
at 200 199 198 the price can drop
and then
you're holding a bunch of million tokens
and then you redeploy more liquidity at
a lower price you can lose money
right because no matter what right like
let's say the price goes down to 100
bucks you deploy more liquidity you
you would have and let's say at that
price you sell out all the tokens then
you would have
lost uh half of your
money by then if you were to do that so
what you're trying to say is that just
like you would provide liquidity from
one dollar to 20
you could also provide it from 20 down
to a dollar so just like you're making
money the price goes up you're also
losing that equivalent money as it goes
down you can lose massive amounts i mean
i remember there was a moment where
um
[Music]
i i put in like a hundred thousand
dollars maybe more of liquidity
in order to try to just support the
current price range and it got wiped out
in four hours
right because some whale decided to just
sell out
[Music]
so
they just cashed out that liquidity
position
so you know it
typically
liquidity is supposed to be a neutral
position it's actually anybody can do it
you know it's like it's not like i'm
special right anyway like anybody can
just come in and add liquidity if they
want so when you're going back and forth
with coffeezilla
how much of that was strategic
of just you're going to drive more
attention to million token because i
watched your videos and i think a lot of
people can't differentiate
you being real versus the sarcasm
and
i like i kind of knowing you would watch
these videos of yours you'd be like
well you know you're being really
sarcastic here but you're it's also
trying to prove a point and it's driving
still more traffic nothing i say is ever
a joke you guys you need to understand
that but
you know i've dealt with coffeezilla
enough before i mean come on i'm
ex-convict but i've dealt with them
enough before to know that many people
especially in his audience are simply up
for a mo punt right like it's kind of
like the twitter
mob coming after you and people have
already made up their minds
they believe what they want to believe
and there's no reasoning with people you
know so it's like yes i can sit down and
give you this long explanation like i've
done already but um it goes with my
prior note my philosophy that
people
believe what they want to believe
you know they they are where they want
to be
and then they come up with all sorts of
self-rationalizations and uh
explanations for why this is the way it
is
um it's kind of like how i tell you you
can't you you can't negotiate love if i
can give somebody the best explanation
in the world
they don't want to if they don't want to
understand
they will will themselves not to so when
i'm debating with coffeezilla
ah
it's just like
just feed into it right like just feed
into just fan the flames you know and
get some views out of it
and
give i can give some explanation which
i've done but at the same time humans
are irrational like i said so
you can
i would say like do you believe
it's necessary to explain anything
right like if somebody asks you for an
explanation
um should you explain why you're a
rational being
hey i'm rational this is why i'm
rational or should you just say
i'm a psychopath you guys humans are
irrational
what do i have to explain it's like
asking a rabbit dog
please explain yourself is like
this
don't expect people to be rational i
don't know sometimes i think a good
explanation goes a long way and a very
calm collected way because i feel like
you're able to articulate something that
might be misconstrued
so if there is something thrown at you
combating that with with points against
it and why the other person might be
incorrect or explaining your point of
view
i do think goes a long way because i i
think people are able to see that and
contextualize it and i don't think you
can
argue with a mob right like have you
tried arguing with the twitter mob
i well i think there's a difference
between arguing with each person
individually and addressing the
situation as a whole so i think
yeah like there are certain comments
that i've received that are like no i'm
not going to respond to this comment but
here's the other thing yeah coffeezilla
never
i don't think he wants an explanation
right like he's ever this is the youtube
game everybody's in it for money
he builds his
business off of
criticizing other people and just
calling
like life like right like is life a scam
yeah it probably is
right is is marriage a scam sure
sure it is it's like is life uh unfair
he should make a video about that hey
life's unfair you guys breaking news
it's like if if he already has in my
view if he already has a perspective and
he doesn't want to sit down and have a
long conversation explanation about this
and you know what he's gonna do he's
going to just clip out whatever he can
and just attack the other person and
just make a video and leave out anything
necessary right so like this is my
problem with criticism culture by the
way
uh criticism is easy
everybody can criticize
i've had
so many people come criticize me in the
past you know like
uh i made a tech interview pro course
right to sell interview tips on how to
get into fang and people come and say
hey this is a scam you guys i this is
scam these people never even took the
course
meanwhile
other people came in and said
let me just see
uh
like let me try to focus on myself
instead of just blaming other people
yeah i heard a story about that and we
could let me ask you if it's true i
heard that there was a competitor i
don't know where i heard this i think it
was a video that i saw
on youtube
someone said that there was a competitor
to your program and their website
expired and you bought their website and
then when people went to their website
it rerouted it to yours
that was a pretty old piece of drama
yeah
and
i mean we we can go into that if you
want no i'm just there's plenty of
content but like
i
i would say
he should focus on himself and focus on
collaboration instead of it's like if
you're trying to tear like let's say you
spend your life turn somebody else down
let's say you spend your life trying to
write all the injustices that were done
to you so you grew up to age
some age and you make a list of
everybody who wronged you in your life
right hey that person uh stole my
website that person stole my piece of
candy i'm gonna go back and just like
get these people back i'm gonna find
justice you got to focus on yourself i
would say event ultimately if you want
to find success
there's no room for anger there's no
room for hate like it's
think about it hate is a luxury right
hate is a luxury that
if you truly
want success you cannot afford
to
uh
like right isn't hate something that
just an anger something that just makes
you feel good but you lose in the
process of pursuing that
so it's it's a luxury that i would say
you cannot afford if if you're truly
going after the highest success
um
you collaborate with everybody
somebody wrongs you you say
cool you're wrong to me
how can we still make the best of this
situation
right instead of saying oh you wronged
me let me burn my bridge with you
let me just burn all of my bridges
let me like get you back and focus my
life on tearing other people down then
you tear yourself down
two
got it
yeah i think what was it i forget
someone a while ago i've had two
instances but it but both of them have
turned out really good one person i
think it was on i think it was tick tock
they got my uh don't like my screen name
just like graham stefan
and uh they were really kind about i
forget
which what it was jack maybe it was tick
tock it wasn't instagram i forget what
it was but anyway um i reached out to
the person they're like oh yeah no i got
it maybe it's clubhouse i got it because
i didn't want anyone else to take it
here you go i'm so nice about it and
then one time my dumb my domain gram
stefan expired and i don't know who did
this but they bought graham stefan.com
and rerouted it to go to meetkevin.com
or like metkevin.com it was like one of
those funny things and i asked kevin i'm
like dude is this you he's like no it's
not me and then eventually they just
they gave it back but i just thought
that was really funny but both of them
have have really good endings this was a
year ago probably over a year ago when
clubhouse first went out
jack just got a whole bunch of i got a
bunch of users a whole bunch like good
usernames i don't we don't have to
mention them specifically but these are
names that like should be reserved for
like the
elite of the elite and jack just i went
in and yanked them all i got my friend's
phone numbers and i was like can i use
your phone number can i use your phone
number because you need to attach it to
a phone number and then i just got them
all together yeah i mean i mean it was
your poor jack this is something but i
asked jack
and guess how much money i got two bucks
five zero dollars tens of thousands of
dollars but i have good views first yeah
if you had cash out you'd make like a
few pennies here's the thing though
now you never know i asked jack this is
like what's your name what's your plan
with this and he's like well if they ask
for it i'm gonna give it to him i'm like
you wouldn't sell it he's like no i
wouldn't sell it but like i would just
give it to him um
the downside though is that in the
beginning you didn't know if it was
gonna go the route of instagram or
eventually like you have a one-word uh
username on instagram that's like 20.
this is jack behind all those youtube
boss you're the one posting on all these
yeah
yeah yeah
but unfortunately clubhouse is just like
really downhill and now all your
usernames are kind of worthless
completely but it was still i mean it
took me what an hour and a half and i
gave myself an opportunity to have i
don't know a lot of upside
he did but but he's got to go 10x jack
yeah but he has good usernames of also
like uh corporations and like this isn't
passive income man no
it was very active and it also wasn't
income so so yeah never what never sell
your time right never sell it well i
also enjoyed it it was kind of fun
because you try a username and it
doesn't work you're like oh what about
this celebrity and you try it and maybe
it works and they'll give you a little
you know a rush it was just a late night
yeah but jack got a few people with with
well over like 40 50 million followers
yeah and
[Music]
yeah
it's a good time
worth nothing now but it's fun yeah yeah
so in terms of uh in terms of your
channel now i've noticed that you've
you've made some we don't have to
mention specifically some controversial
opinions and topics lately between some
channels
how much of that is simply for the shock
value of let me say the most out there
thing i'm against the current thing
what's up i'm against the current thing
whatever the current thing is pretty
much like whatever it is you'll take the
opposite stance of it but i notice when
you do that the views are like 5x what
they would be any other way
a lot of pushback but at the end do you
just see this as like a if i say this or
i take this stance
the there's more upside than downside or
no i will move on or i think it comes
down to um like i stopped reading
mainstream news
right because
there's no alpha there like everything
there is priced into the market so
if if all you do is follow mainstream
news you will always be one step behind
you know
yahoo finance is going to come and say
um
this is what you should believe in
whatever right like uh
some markets doing well
um
but that's all priced into the market
everybody's seen that so you have to
think
by yourself and oftentimes go against
the herd right because that's where you
find
new thoughts new opinions and ideas and
where you're really at the forefront
right and so you have to keep your mind
open and just question
and ask yourself questions like just ask
yourself like is this really the truth
don't just believe what whatever you
read um that's where the so to speak
alpha is right that's where the reward
is um
so personally for right it's like i
avoid mainstream news i like to read
controversial news i mean even on elon
musk right recently took a hold of
twitter to say that there's no free
speech anymore yeah if you say anything
that is against current
uh mind speak the current thing or
belief whatever like
uh you could be canceled for sure
but
then you don't find returns on
investment you don't find opportunities
because you're just following the hurt
all the time
so what i like to do sometimes on my
channel at least is
i present different opinions right
different points of view ask people to
question themselves
and
this is something that
like
let's think about your upbringing
you were raised with certain values your
teachers your mentors your parents all
came to you and said
these are things that are important
these are things that these are your
values
so then you go into the world
and you're afraid to reflect your values
into the world you're quiet
so the flame that they lit in you to
stand up and speak your voice was
extinguished because you're too afraid
to speak
right you let the voices of others drown
you out
maybe
and this is maybe a freedom that's only
provided to uh
people who are not able to be canceled
like may
maybe if you really want to reflect the
values and respect
everybody you met in your life who gave
you the values and beliefs that you
currently hold
and these people spend so much time and
effort trying to get you to believe in
these things and hold these values that
are so strong
maybe you should reflect those values
into the world too simply to show
respect to every mentor and teacher that
you encountered in your life
but when you let other people just drown
you out
uh because you're afraid
you're showing disrespect
to anybody who put any time in you they
should have just said
why am i even wasting time with you
right why am i even trying to teach you
anything
when you're going to just colored out
and just be quiet
because you didn't want to speak up and
then if you were to speak up enough
about whatever it is right like
um maybe even just saying hey guys maybe
we should think about this
i'm not sure if i believe this
um
like maybe if enough people say that
together that forms an opinion that
forms a voice
is it okay to be
some people don't want to be the first
candle
that lights up
right because they're afraid to go
against
against that crowd
maybe you're a follower
uh that's why i'm the tech lead right
like maybe maybe you need to lead and
like initiative
is extremely uh difficult to find them
people impact
you probably know
most people are extremely low impact low
initiative people zero initiative right
like um this is what separates tech lead
by the way from
software engineer
so where software engineers by the way
they only do what they're told to do
the intro company they're great coders
you give them a task they do it solid
engineer great you did the task
the senior engineer what separates them
is initiative and impact
so you need to take initiative you need
to come and say
i've seen enough of the world i have
experience i know what's right
or i know what's worth pursuing what's
exploring here's an idea
and not only is it something worth
thinking about but we need to make it a
reality and actually execute on this
idea and take that initiative
right so like very few people do that
most people say
hey wouldn't it be cool if uh somebody
made this
hey i had an idea for an app that's
that's kind of interesting
hey this is somebody should do that
sometime yeah i'm gonna do it one day
one day i'm gonna go to uh south america
and explore one day i'm gonna go scuba
diving in fiji with all of my friends
uh are you ever gonna do that
right like probably maybe it's never
gonna happen because maybe
you have sufficient initiative and
impact
to execute
right and and that execution can be
extremely ugly it's where the rubber
hits the road between what dream and
reality
right between sky and ground
that's a very dirty messy part sparks
are flying
um but you have to get in there
sometimes and
yeah people can disagree with you there
can be a lot of mess going on
it's not a place that a lot of people
want to be it can push you out of your
comfort zone
uh it can make you look like a fool your
pride your ego your status can get in
your way
you may still need to just say
let me go make a fool of myself let me
humiliate myself
and by doing that you take initiative
why did you leave california
some of that i know was you know maybe
some of the some of the taxes yeah how
did i end up in this
i know you randomly made a video
complaining about dry skin and just yeah
just washing my face with hard mineral
water that's just scratching it's going
to make you age more
yeah just aging and
dry air just so why are you trying now
socially you just can't seem right yeah
but if money was a it was a
consideration wouldn't you just say i'm
going to live in california where it's
where my skin's going to be better are
you here for the money for the your tax
savings your that's definitely a
component but i would say for me i would
say taxes is one of them but the
lifestyle is is a huge component of just
i feel like i'm getting way more than i
would be able to do in california las
vegas is very functional right it's very
nice actually so far from what i've seen
like i i spend time in san francisco and
it's it's total trash it's a total trash
pile of a city like everything boarded
up but
um i mean this is where like
if you're rich enough you end up in a
desert in the middle of nowhere right
like
if you're if you're kind of middle class
you might be in a nice city like new
york making your way los angeles or
something like san francisco
um
really for me after i figured out like
after i totally trashed this city and
told everyone how how trashy it is hey
i'm here you guys i'm in las vegas now
you know why i don't have friends
um
but
for me it was
a decision
like i i realized that if if i'm gonna
be my plan is actually to do more
traveling right to integrate more
traveling into my life so if that's my
plan it simply doesn't make sense to
get what like a nice seaside apartment
in los angeles or something where i'm
paying
whatever rent it is and i'm not using
the space
right so
it's the cost of living i would say for
las vegas
that
gets you something pretty good um
for a price that's not going to just
you know like it's not going to be
something that you're you're not even
paying for
uh
or it's not going to be excessive to
that point it's pretty reasonable here
so
yeah
i wouldn't say the tax savings are
meaningful
at all really there's like 10 tax
savings is not meaningful
you should go to puerto rico right like
if you if you're really after tax
savings go to puerto rico
um
so to me it's kind of like it's a pretty
decent cost of living base from which is
close enough to california for me if if
my family were on the east coast i would
definitely go to puerto rico
right but
since i still have family and i have a
dog i need to take care of over in
california occasionally i like to go
back and visit so
las vegas makes sense and it's a
pretty interesting change of pace and i
think i mean this is an experiment kind
of for me but you know i've i've been
interested in travel and ex like i'm
trying to maximize experiences i have i
have very little interest in material
things you know like i i don't know a
nice watch i don't own a nice car i
don't own the house i don't want it on
the house you know like your aquarium
uh
exploded right it's like i don't want to
maintain that i i have no interest in
fixing anything my hands are for
typing that's it right as a digi like i
live in the metaverse
but
um so i'm trying to focus more on
traveling and experiences and las vegas
is it's a great base
for that
so that's that's kind of my current plan
but i'm not here to save money i think
saving money is um
it's a waste of uh youth and time like
i'm not sure i believe in saving money
even anymore like i believe
if there's a young person who has youth
time and health and they're only lacking
in wealth but they have every other
capacity to maximize happiness and
enjoyment
maybe they should deploy that capital at
that point in their life to maximize
that than waiting until they're 60 or 70
and they're not able to deploy capital t
but it's all easy to say that when you
have the money
because then it's easy to go back and be
like well you know i did i got this i
could
focus on the other aspects but when you
have no wealth and it's it's a grind of
like well i have to suck it up at this
job for the next 30 years just to pay my
just to break even every day it's not
like it's like enjoy the journey
right i
so i don't think like
you can
like what
you've got to maximize enjoyment every
step of your life if you think
what i'd like to think of is right like
if
the most successful of people are
doctors and lawyers they achieve wealth
early retirement at the best
age 40 maybe age 50.
but then their life is over right it's
like uh so you've
and that's in the best case scenario so
you have to
make sure you're enjoying life every
step of the way and and deploy i think
you need to find ways to deploy capital
to do that because as you get older
and
you know you're going to realize that
you cannot derive enjoyment anymore from
your
from money you know you may find that
it's or you may find it very difficult
to deploy in a way to make yourself see
i see it as a means to an end if you if
you have a job that you dislike and
you're 25 years old you have you have
health but he's talking about you
well let me talk about me specifically
has anybody saved their way to riches i
think so
i i think like
we all made our wealth through
focusing more on making money
than on
saving on like
starbucks i mean i did that i mean it's
hard for me because i
saved everything i lived so cheap i mean
i would i'd even a five dollar subway
like i thought about that purchase and
i'm like do i really need the five
dollar subway or can i do uh
uh eat at two eggs and ham and cheese
for 97 cents
i did that too but i think it's
i think it's a scam story that the media
sells you as an easy way for anybody
hey we can all
become rich
here's how it's so easy all you got to
do
is
skip lunch
when the answer is
far more difficult than people want to
hear go start a business
go apply yourself and make money it's
easier to make money
than to save it
who wants to hear that i don't know part
of me thought it was easier to save than
make
because if you if if i save a dollar i'm
saving a dollar after tax if i'm going
and making an extra dollar i'm taxed on
that it's worth less than just if i
saved it so for the first from really 18
to 30. i was just like hyper fixated on
just saving and those those habits i
would there'd be no way i'd be here
today if it weren't for those habits
that were so ingrained from the very
beginning of just like save save save
save save it was the habits but it
wasn't necessarily the saving itself
right yeah i mean obviously if i were
making 15 000 a year but i was saving 14
000 of it and you know
then obviously i i wouldn't be here
today either but but i think it was a
combination of
saving everything but then also actively
working on you know improving myself and
making more money at the same time if
you're a young person
uh use the money that you have don't
save it and deploy it into like
learning something right acquire some
skill
use the money to
go to business
i think so much learning could be done
for free like a lot besides books
um
i i learned everything from youtube and
read it i mean that's
like and then if there was something i
didn't know i would learn it in real
estate i would i would talk to other
agents i just it was my time i spent my
time
let's just put it this way there's so
much advice online and from every like
dave ramsey person who's saying
uh
you need to cut back cut your budget
you need to like pack your lunches
everybody feels that's actionable they
feel good about themselves nobody's
saying hey why don't you like
uh start a youtube channel
why don't you like build a course why
don't you try to teach something like
why don't you like build a product start
a business
nobody tells you that
so everybody's just out there saying
okay 401k
let's let's let's max out that 401k you
guys well because those those are i want
to say those are pretty surefire
guaranteed ways that people could have
instant results i think starting a
business a lot of them fail
doing a lot of these things a lot of
them fail so
by focusing on the core of the
foundation of these i know contributing
to a roth ira saving money
that's money in my pocket that's
guaranteed anything i do beyond that
that's where i take the risk but let me
at least have my fortress over here and
that gives me the safety and the
reassurance that i could focus on
whatever else i want and once those pay
off
or if they pay off then i could take
that route it also is like yeah like he
said it's the safety and reassurance
that you know for a fact if you do end
up saving money that is completely
within your control is that you can save
money you can invest it and it's a safe
way to to collect a lot of money rather
than going and starting a business
starting a youtube channel where you
have so many so much chaos and variables
yeah you're poor
hey like i bought a house
this year you're poor like look yeah let
the millionaire speak okay i'm not
talking about graham i'm talking about
me the true millionaire
i have a question for you graham yeah uh
how much money were you making per year
when you hit a million dollars net worth
uh somewhere between 150 and 220 a year
probably maybe two f
no more than 250 definitely in my
opinion 120 to 250 i think that you
you didn't
make yourself wealthy by all the penny
punching i agree with tech lead no i i
would disagree i think it were it would
first of all there would have been no
way
first of
there had been no way that i could have
bought those all of those properties
that contributed to that net worth and
that that foundation of income had i not
saved every single penny even at the
time i bought those first few properties
uh i was still like two thousand dollars
short and i didn't have money to pay a
contractor and i had a tenant moving in
shortly and
i had i went to my grandma let me ask
you she and she gave me two grand i'd be
like thanks grandma i'll pay you back in
three weeks i'm literally getting this
money from she couldn't give you three
grand could you have driven ubers
driving uber on the weekends no i was
working on the weekends i was a real
estate agent and those weekends i would
go up to uh to san bernardino check out
properties
from i was
and here's how i know this
at eight i think i was 18 or 19. my
girlfriend at the time throughout high
school broke up with me and i was so
sad and depressed because you weren't
too cheap
she's graham
it's you need to buy that starbucks no
no that's that's what it costs you for
being no no it didn't work
oh my gosh you don't know what you lost
no i i know it had not it had nothing to
do with money
and that was absolutely yeah if you had
focused more on making money you would
be a billionaire now
right and in comparison you're only a
millionaire now so that's what it costs
i feel like but you could say the same i
could be a billionaire you'd be like
well you could always be worth 10
billion dollars
you know or you could if you focused
more on this you'd be more but but my
point being is that when i went through
that my way out of it my escape was just
like i'm gonna put everything i can into
bettering myself improving myself going
to the gym
and any moment of free time i poured
myself into work because that was my
like outlet and that was my uh creative
just
i felt alive doing that i had so much
fun doing that and that was like made
the days fly by because i enjoyed it so
much but
yeah i mean but
i saved every little bit of that because
i knew that that my income was so
sporadic as an agent that
that's what gave me comfort was being
like okay if i make a commission i can
save it i also
in a competitive sense felt like
i could net more than the agents who's
been doing this for
20 years because
i've seen how they live i mean they'll
spend everything they make they make 300
grand if they're spending 300 grand
they've got nothing left over but if i
could make
50 grand
and save 25 of it then technically i'm
saving more than they are
and that's how i've yeah yeah i mean
if your spend rate is extremely high
then then yes maybe my spend rate just
tends to be low either way
um but in in either case it's just a
it's just a recognition for me that
there's a lot of mainstream media saying
hey just put it into 401k save your
money that's how you're gonna become
rich and i'm just questioning that
narrative right it's like
uh i'm a futurist i tend to think
whether people want 100 years in the
future people are gonna look back and
laugh at us and say we were totally
idiots
so
like
right now everyone thinks 401k and
saving money is the way to go in the
future everyone's going to say something
else
right they may say yeah this is totally
flawed
question that well i i think the end
goal is that there's probably both i'm
not a huge fan of the 401k i much prefer
the roth but i
if someone makes more than six thousand
dollars a year i would do anything
possible to tell that person save
everything you can until you max out
that roth ira
whether you're eighteen nineteen twenty
five doesn't i would tell the person
like
buy a dslr camera and start a youtube
channel
right like start the business
maybe use that and learn programming
and
right get a job as a coder instead of
just saving that and
and working a dead end job
and you're going to save like 50 bucks
but see the issue that i that i see is
that people view either let's say in
your youtube channel example as a means
to and i'd be like i'm going to start
the channel make a ton of money everyone
who i've seen who's on youtube has done
youtube for fun first
and if it takes off great and and that
will eventually evolve over time but
everyone's successful that i've seen
never started being like
i'm not going to max out my roth ira i'm
going to start the youtube channel and
make a lot of money it just i've never
seen that happen
uh i would agree with that that money is
an extremely poor motivator
and people should not
be chasing money in the first place
like i it's it's not going to
you get money you're just going to throw
into bitcoin or crypto or something like
that it's like
figure out the life you want
many people even if they achieve massive
wealth like you
say the life i actually wanted was to
stay at home reading news and making
videos all day
that's actually what i wanted well you
didn't need wealth to get that
i think the money gives options and it
gives the person the option to say hey
you know what i don't feel like doing
this today or maybe 10 years from now if
i want to do this i can
that's where i think the value is
because otherwise if i knew that i'd be
perfectly happy just making a video
every day and
so be it but i don't i don't know if
that's going to last forever i've always
just gone with the hey this feels right
this is what i want to do this is where
where my intuition leads me i'm going to
pursue that it's always been like that
so and having money gives me the means
to pursue yeah whatever it might be
i would say money is is definitely
useful
most people who have it
don't know how to deploy it and never
use it properly
but if you know how to figure out how to
actually deploy that and maximize
that in conjunction with your other
assets right like health wealth youth
and time
uh you may be able to figure out how to
actually use it properly but
generally it's it's very difficult i
would say to deploy money in a way
that's
going to bring you happiness right some
people just buy a
car
that makes them happy for a month and
they lost
500 000
and they gave them one month of joy
right i mean right not if they buy a
ford gt that goes up in value then they
can make money
and enjoy the car
i mean
i can tell your status just from that
it's like pretty cheap like it's not not
very rich i mean
you think that's expensive that
what's what's expensive to you what what
would impress you be like wow graham has
a
lexus lfa mclaren f1 it would be like uh
oh nina catamaran out in the british
virgin islands right it's like
well you're you're a land lander you
just go around on land
well all right if that's what you enjoy
you know some people got catamarans out
there
yeah i'd still need to transcend i'm
going to work on that
yeah you'll get there keep working on it
if you're here i'm like
right around there i know that's why
that's why i'm i always have to look
jack you're like
under the table by now jack has to
transcend to where's bailey and where's
alex
they're they're not even i mean they're
they're not worthy they're successful
but like this table is even they're not
even worthy of this the table is worth
more than me why isn't this table gold
plated this is trash this whole studio's
trash how much was that how much was
that jacket you're wearing
this is um
this is top-notch stuff it's made out of
ex-husband material
this is a gift yeah this is a gift from
my ex-wife you know how much she cost me
half my assets there you go yeah that's
how expensive it is that's how much it
was
no this and i mean this
you know this is like i i wear outing
gear right it's like it's uh it's a
status list classless i would say so
if you're wearing like prada or gucci i
know your social level right away it's
like it's not that not that out there so
what do you think you can work on i mean
what i'm working on now is is really
this new project for me for myself which
is
i'm curious about can have can money by
happiness
everybody says no
everybody says oh money can't can't make
you happy i'm i'm trying to
understand that and to challenge that
belief
i'm trying to
um
find more creative ways to deploy
capital right like i told you i it's
autopilot
and extremely lazy to just go through
life selling on the nine to five course
and to just continue working like elon
musk
is living uh
it's a very boring uh
like it's it's nice that he's doing that
but it's also a thoughtless path that
requires your creativity are the people
who are
i'm inspired by tom from myspace he quit
social media entirely
like three four years ago he disappeared
went off to like explore nature
you know i think some of these other
people you never hear about are
living
probably the best lives out there right
so like i'm i'm trying i'm challenging
some of those beliefs for myself
um and that's kind of the current thing
that i'm trying to explore so for me
like saving money investing money
is it's a boring pursuit to me and i'm
i'm personally more interested in just
figuring out how to deploy capital in a
meaningful way
thank you so much for coming on it was
really nice meeting you i appreciate it
a lot mentorship group linked down below
yeah you can also get your free free
free stuff yeah yeah
with the code grandma
g-r-a-h-a-m
thank you for having me guys thank you
it was nice meeting you i really
appreciate it thank you for coming here
and
until next time bailey what is it
wanna get it